Okay, is it okay for a cancer patient to take
El glutamine for a short period of time?
This person is referring to what I talk about
quite frequently that a cancer patient
should not be on glutamine supplementation
because glutamine is one of the amino acids
that can be a direct fuel source for cancer.
However, let's say you're in a fairly good state
of remission, but you have major gut issues.
And you want to heal the gut.
Can you go on a glutamine supplement for a short period of time?
My answer is yes, you can.
I would say a lower dose glutamine supplement.
Now, there are some glutamine.
So, El glutamine is a supplement that is used to help heal the gut.
Why is it used to help heal the gut?
Because glutamine helps stimulate cell reproduction.
Quite readily, let's stimulate cell reproduction.
Well, I wouldn't even want to do that
but if I have cancer, well, if your cancer's in remission
and it's not a intestinal cancer, let's say it's breast cancer,
but you know, your Evan remission, I do really well.
Now, I got to heal my gut.
I'm having major gut problems.
I say it's okay to take glutamine for a short period of time.
But I mean, maybe for a month or maybe two months
and not take high dose glutamine
because there are glutamine supplements
that are four or five grams of glutamine.
I think that's way too much.
I think taking less than a gram of glutamine
would be your best way to do it.
We have a product called Clear GI.
It has one and a half grams glutamine in it,
but it's a powder.
So, you don't have to take a whole scoop.
So, if you take a half scoop,
you're getting 750 milligrams of glutamine.
It has a really, really good gut healing.
It's a gut healing supplement.
So, it's got all these other great supplements
that will help heal the gut.
It's a great supplement.
Now, the person has got more active cancer.
Then you go and you're working on trying to heal the gut.
Then you think of something like gastrobed.
That has got less things,
but it's got that deglycerized licorice,
which is so healing for the gut.
The TR Clear GI also has that licorice in it,
but if you want to stay away from glutamine altogether,
then you still want to risk it.
Then you go with the gastrobed supplement.
But remember, you've got to start with your healing
and you have to start from the top down.
So, are you chewing your fluid well?
Are you, do you have HCL issues?
That's the, again, the number one digestive problem.
And that's how so many digestive problems start
is because of a decreased HCL production.
Well, how does that happen?
Well, it happens because of stress,
kind of because of dietary issues,
damaging those cells in the stomach that make HCL,
so you need to support it by adding HCL
and digestive enzymes to your diet where you eat
and then it might be necessary to heal the gut.
Now, we'll get, I have multiple videos on HCL
and healing the gut and how HCL deficiency
so often leads to H. Pylora.
If you look back to Pylora, I have videos on that.
It blog posts on that, so make sure you take a look at that.